every Wednesday our morning rounds
series will look at medical issues that
impact you and solutions to help make
you healthier this morning we're sharing
some simple ways to fight seasonal
allergies we all have those it's
estimated nearly one in six Americans
struggle with them and more than 22
million people in the u.s. live in areas
where pollen levels are high right now
our doctor Tara Narula is here with how
to outsmart allergy triggers Tara good
morning good morning so how do we what
is the best way to help minimize this
because it's like you know it seems to
come out of nowhere yes so you can't
outsmart it you don't have to be
miserable you don't know the first thing
you can do is really check the pollen
counts so the national allergy bureau
has a website you can go to as well as
others and apps where you can see is
this a day where I may not want to spend
as much time outside also the hours of 5
a.m. to 10 a.m. and the late in the
evenings tend to be worse for allergy
sufferers hot dry windy day is also
worse when you think about getting
dressed you want to think about movie
stars so big sunglasses broad brimmed
hat also if you wear contacts you may
want to wear your glasses on that day
and interestingly synthetic fibers tend
to attract more pollen than natural
fibers like cotton when you get in your
car you want to keep the windows closed
no sunroof recycle the air and when you
mow the lawn it may not look cute but
you want to wear a mask so there are
definitely things you can do no I like
that don't think like movie stars I like
my lawnmower yeah how do you avoid
tracking the pollen and everything else
in your house so that your house also
becomes like a park exactly so you want
your house to be pollen proof so first
of all close your windows as tempting as
it might be to get that fresh air you
want to keep them closed no fan use an
air conditioner and maybe purchase a
HEPA filter and then you want to strip
strip strip so before you get in your
house take your shoes off leave them
outside take your clothes off put them
in the washing machine and get in the
shower wash your hair because what you
don't want to do is get them pollen all
over your bed and on your pillowcases
what you're breathing in all night and
it's in the vestibule strip strip strip
not on the lawn no one can see you don't
want police call yeah and you want your
partner to shower too yes or the bed
with you and then you want to vacuum
pretty often change the vacuum bag
side of the house so these are simple
steps you can take so is there a certain
medication you think we should really
pay attention to well medication is
definitely important and they do say to
start treatment
two weeks before allergy season starts
the first line of therapy is really
nasal steroids but then there are
antihistamines decongestants and for
certain people allergy shots and even
immunotherapy if there are other home
remedies for this sort of thing so there
are some that people recommend first of
all nasal spray or saline and kind of
wash out the pollen some people use a
neti pot with distilled water or boiled
water and then I know that's effective
but God is I know its effect it works it
is yeah I heard some people say
probiotics acupuncture maybe honey
turmeric or apple cider vinegar if you
have those in your house might help dr.
olla thank you very much I feel armed
for the season that's what she does